gallery vous c'est drôle je suis jamais
majorité du temps à rigoler de voir des
choses qu'on a fait comme ça c'est
marrant cet essai à quelques années
parce que j'arrive à faire les voix un
peu plus aiguë 4 c'est pour ça taxer
tous les parents des taxes et non pacsés
oui tous les cas une interview oui j'ai
validé avant je veux dire que nos amis
du téléspectateur
oui ceux qui ont le cap canal satellite
le câble numérique qui peuvent retrouver
kad et olivier donc dans la grosse
émission de leur tour à 19 heures à 19
heures c'est s'emmerde la nuit ça 23,62
camarades pouvions les décidé d'y
aménager vie axelle laffont philippe
lelièvre foraine prévost nicolas deuil
les ruba nadda aiguë sous les cris aigüs
c'est pour ça vous ne citez pas non plus
de faire partie de l'équipe au début
puis l'émission c'est vrai je n'ai pas
peur de vous retrouver sur gaspard hier
ça vous fait très très peur et ont aussi
préparé par mois comment il avait vécu
on va avoir la grosse tête de chou dans
un temps on va on voit sur des trucs un
peu ses rapports avec les lis beaucoup
liés bon alors est-ce qu'on peut baisser
la lumière s'il vous plaît
ces derniers cette lumière là c'est vrai
bon je pose la question aux deux on va
raquer là le plus rapide des deux
d'accord vous avez un portrait chinois
donc si tu étais une fleur qu'est-ce que
tu serais qu'est-ce que tu serais si tu
étais une fleur toi un myosotis à cause
de ses yeux je sais pas c'est une seule
une rose une route et une fleur une
marguerite gérard le sol pour patrick
aujourd'hui non et en face on ne sait
pas c'est vrai non pas la coiffure la
ligue ne fait pas les cheveux longs la
vie polyphonie pas le physique pas les
cheveux quand les parents comment ils se
parlent pas de fleurs je dis si tu étais
un [ __ ] du strict et comme [ __ ] le
salon de l'agriculture samedi mais les a
fêtés
si tu étais un défaut olivier oui oui si
vous étiez une injure vous soyez quoi
comme un dur moi j'aime bien petite
crotte
oui moi je dis non je laisse dans sa
mère devant la gare si vous étiez une
maladie ou feriez quoi comme maladie
l'ange une blanche mais c'est bien j'ai
beau jaune moi je vais les couleurs pour
la couleur un accident sa coiffure
patrick sébastien sanchez ben je voulais
qu ils mettent des trucs dessus tu
t'imagines sommet qui se retrouver comme
ça moi sauvage
moi je suis concentré sur porte chinoise
on m'a dit rester concentré
si vous étiez une perversion alors très
très bien justement j'étais une
perversion moi je veux dire vrai si on
était une vengeance est une malformation
si vous étiez une guerre la guerre de
cent ans je pense la cheville et ça a
duré longtemps
c'est trop long on n'avait pas de bonne
guerre pour briquet pour les laisser
club allons faire manger pas tous les
jours un dictateur
le coiffeur de patrick sébastien
pour les univers les doigts plus si vous
étés 1 bis vous étiez à vis vis à vis
non non non service qui est 4e au lit
ville je suis avec les vieilles calcaire
dit moi je sais plus là moi je suis le
réel
ok tu étais un supplice supplice être
obligé de regarder patrie sébastien
savez les cheveux sur un filon là alors
on va faire parler de soi quand c'est
d'autres invités de la pub si vous étiez
un poison à la latte harbin lazare dit
ouais vous pas trouvé un truc sur mes
cheveux tu regardes métier une infirmité
la coiffure de ben ali sont qui me
connaît bien
t'as pas grever de maddie la coiffure
moi je veux non mais moi je souhaite et
je le dis je le dis aux millions de gens
qui nous regardent
écrivez nous tous en marotte écoles vont
dire que patrick garde sa chute grave de
toute façon mais oui pour moi ça sera
non seulement la crinière de lion c'est
joli c'est joli ça j'avais plus poétique
que ça me faisait au moins deux queues
de cheval
s'il tient à sa balle on l'a vite heures
le coiffeur de la prison si vous étiez
une humiliation il m'annonçait continue
et moi ça me gêne pas ça va vous laisser
vous non le book de patrick sébastien
c'est bien et si vous étiez un animateur
télé
ben voila apres nausicaa patrick
sébastien patois télé une minute pour
patrick savatier
bougies tout ça au soleil
bonsoir pas fait que j'en ai vu des
pires depuis
oui c'est ce que j'allais dire la non
pas pourquoi il n'ya pas patrick
sabatier l'être humain il à le dire mais
j'aurais dit linda hardy comme ça
j'aurais pu me regarder dans une glace à
poil et me toucher les niches c'est pas
idiot dans ta raison qu'à moi je me
disais qu'un production attention linda
vous les connaissez déjà scolaire s'est
croisé mon chemin je crois si on
rentrait aux stands et manèges
je me souviens je n'ai pas ligne s'est
pas plaint
comme ça avec nous non oui vraiment
rester beau rester tous pour allumer la
lumière si vous voulez ou alors on reste
dans l'art est entre gens de télé on est
bien dans l'oubli quand et comme elles
avaient patrie quand les bleus mais
c'est bon ça fait rire tout le monde
attend je sais de carson un peu devant
une petite personne un peu de com
chapelet k ster wenn jacques chirac
austère et 3,1 crise se nourrit aux
hormones bon j accueille maintenant
notre m